hey guys it is the 13th of January today
my name is Jess and you're watching
games but new rainbow six siege is
already no friend to cheetahs and now
they're planning to release an update
with a beefed-up anti-cheating measures
update 1.3 will be released on January
13 for pc and january twenty on consoles
it's aiming to target cheaters by fixing
a number of exploits improving the
existing anti-cheating measures and
update the banning policy wherein all
cheaters detected by the system will be
banned permanently as in one strike and
you're out permanently the update is
also addressing level design bugs online
and matchmaking issues as well as
general tweaks and improvements in
sounds like PlayStation Plus extension
codes may be on their way to make up the
PlayStation Network outages earlier this
month according to a VG 24-7 report the
sony has begun sending out emails to
users who had an active PlayStation Plus
membership during the outage it's
expected that these extensions will also
cover PlayStation now and video rental
services since the news isn't official
at this stage there are no details on
how sony plan to apply the membership
extension or how long journey will
extend subscriptions after the infamous
Christmas 2014 outage that left game is
without access to PSN in nearly a week
Sony offered five-day extensions to
PlayStation subscribers additionally the
playstation twitter account announced
that software update 3.15 for ps4 is due
to be released tonight which will be a
minor update designed to improve system
performance finally titanfall zabatha
respawn entertainment is reportedly
working on a new third person action
game in addition to
titanfall to a respawn job listing
posted on Gamasutra calls for quote
designers the two game development
projects a new game in the titanfall
universe as well as a new third-person
action-adventure IP the listing goes on
to say respawn is seeking a senior level
designer to embrace and contribute to
the project vision breathing life into
the gameplay world and helping to find a
moment-to-moment player experience this
isn't completely new information as
studio co-founder Vince Zampella said at
the end of 2014 that there was a second
team at the studio working on something
non titanfall related let me know down
in the comments section what kind again
you'd like to see next from the
titanfall team you can also head the
games that we've got stories on a new
pool at four seasons mods and characters
from the focus on fighting game that is
everything I've got for you today they
do remember to leave me your thoughts on
today's stories and I will see you again
tomorrow